one of the things that's really
distinctive about the greatest investors
and probably the people who are the
greatest at everything is they're
self-aware enough that they say yeah I'm
not going to play that game that's not
one that suits my talents it's not one
that suits my temperament and then you
want to focus really obsessively on that
area that is important to you this
doesn't just apply to investing in a
place that every area of life to think
what am I optimized for like stick to
games that you can win think about the
destination think about what you want to
become the type of person you want to be
in terms of your health in terms of your
career in terms of relationships in
terms of your finances your financial
Independence and then work backwards and
think about what's going to get me there
what are the inputs and then pick a
handful of habits both it often talks
about the importance of saying no to
almost everything he just sticks with
what he's good at and his way of
operating his way of thinking when
you're in various States like being
hungry angry lonely tired in pain or
stress you make terrible decisions
you're kind of primed to make terrible
decisions so just being aware that your
decision making about your future about
how to talk to your boss about how to
talk to your employee about how to talk
to your your partner your kid your dog
whatever or what investment to make is
actually going to thank you so one of
the most important things you want to do
both in investing in life is to take
control over your inner life and so we
don't have control over inflation we
don't have control of whether the
Market's going up or not anyone who
tends that they can even predict whether
the market is going up or what inflation
is going to be or where war is going to
break out is either fooling you or
fooling in Stars so these are things we
don't have control over and so what you
want to focus on is the stuff that you
do control what's up believe nation in
today's interview I get to sit down with
the famous author William green he's
best known for writing the book richer
wiser happier which exactly covers that
if you want to be richer wiser and
happier then you need to read the this
book I've read this book maybe five
times now and basically William green
covers and interviews the most famous
investors who and their path to Growing
wealth wisdom and happiness so if that
is interesting to you then you need to
sit back relax and hear the insights of
William green enjoy I've read your book
three times now that this year alone
just listening to it on audiobook and
walking in the forest and you know just
binge watching it three times now so
it's definitely been my favorite book so
I'm just so excited to connect with you
um thank you that's all we'd hear I'd
highly recommend for people who are
watching too definitely check it out but
I'm very curious uh on your book butcher
wise are happier what was the The key
thing that made you write it in the
first place gosh well it took me so long
to write it took me about five years to
write so so I have to cost my mind back
for years but but what what basically
happened is I'd been interviewing these
great investors in a fairly scatter shot
way over about 20 or so years and so I
would interview someone like Jack Bogle
20 years ago who is the founder of
Vanguard which now manages over seven
trillion dollars and that that he's kind
of the king of index funds he he kind of
invented that movement basically or I'd
interview someone like Peter Lynch this
legendary investor from Fidelity who had
this astonishing record for something
like 13 years and then quit at the top
of the game so yeah I would go off to
the Bahamas and spend a day with Sir
John Templeton who was probably the
greatest stock picker Global stock
picker of the 20th century so I'd had
all of these interviews over the years
and and then a few years ago probably
about six or seven years ago I started
to realize there's something actually
quite special going on here that these
guys and they are I'm embarrassed to say
usually guys they you usually old or
middle-aged white guys
um uh to an embarrassing degree they
think in a way that's really valuable
and they're extremely pragmatic and and
they'll basically do anything that works
to give them an advantage so they'll
study any field whether it's Buddhist
Meditation techniques or the science of
habit or
um just studying how to think better or
studying history or economics or
anything behavioral psychology and so
they're kind of an amazing filter to
view the whole world because unlike most
of us most of us are just sort of scavo
shot and well you know we react to
whatever comes along these guys they're
thinking about how to give themselves an
edge in every area of life and I just I
hadn't really read anyone writing about
this in a systematic way and I was
thinking well how can I actually be a a
kind of Bridge to the regular person to
say look you really want to understand
what people like Templeton figured out
what Charlie Munger who's Buffett's 98
year old polymathic genius of a partner
figured out because they'll actually
help you to think better and and then
the really strange and counter-intuitive
thing that I decided to write about at a
certain point was I was thinking well
yeah they can help you get rich but
actually they can help you live more
wisely and that's a really
counter-intuitive argument because
usually we we watch things like
successional billions and we look at
these people and we think God there's
such snakes and my two favorite shows
they are good shows aren't they and and
they just create chaos and lawsuits and
they're totally rapacious and horrible
human beings yeah I'm much more
interested in the this this subset of
people on on Wall Street who have what
Charlie Munger refers to as worldly
wisdom system and so they're actually
thinking about how to live so they're
thinking about these issues of well
what's actually going to make for a
successful in an abundant life is it
going to be just maximizing the amount
of money I make and so I'm a total snake
and leaving a trail of Destruction and
lawsuits in my wake or or should I be
thinking about how to give the money
away what's actually going to make my
life happy or should I behave ethically
is there is it a disadvantage in life to
behave ethically or actually an
advantage because you attract better
people into your orbit and so they're
thinking quite philosophically about
these issues and so I became just
consumed by this idea and I just thought
that's pretty cool if I can if I can try
to provide almost an Investor's Guide to
Life you know so it's not just about how
to how to invest and get rich but
actually about how to live so it was a
madly ambitious project and and once I
started it I was like what have I done
how did I how did I get myself into this
deep mud and it was like it it was like
climbing a series of about 10 different
everests because they're probably about
10 or 11 chapters so each one was like
yeah now I'll now I'll explain how you
should deal with the fact that
everything is impermanent and life
changes and you can't predict the future
so it's like these massive topics uh so
so that that was what inspired me and
yeah your book was uh a beautiful
crossover of uh personal development and
investing
um you know two of my favorite subjects
which is I think why I've binge it so
many times okay
um but uh sorry yeah definitely very
successful in accomplishing that goal um
and is there anything that you actually
changed in the way that in in terms of
your own habits is there anything you
took out of it that you thought yeah I
should actually do that in my life yeah
uh the the biggest thing is well a
couple of big things is some of the
things that impacted me the most was you
know Nick sleeps philosophy on
like returning money to shareholders
when the the fund was getting too too
big
and making sure that
his morals were directly tied with his
results
um and it's not just about money like
you're saying how do you capture as much
as possible
um and then really thinking about a lot
of like the the traits you laid out in
the book because my goal in life is
actually to become a great investor
myself and so trying to model after the
people you laid out
um how they think you know Howard marks
calls it the second level thinking
um and how each of the people you just
refer to have an innovation stack almost
of like you know uh someone is amazing
at philosophy and history and and
Mathematics while the other person is
personal development and
um uh more so political sciences and and
so trying to figure out what would be
based on my skill sets my Innovation
stack what would I love to give me a
Competitive Edge
um yeah that's such an important idea
that I think one of one of the things
that I came to believe really strongly
after spending a lot of time with all of
these people
is you have to think really carefully
about what you bring to the game about
playing playing the hand that you've
been dealt and so I think one of the
things that's extraordinary about all of
these people
is that they're kind of avoiding games
that they can't win and they're focusing
on games that they can win so
that
so for someone for someone like Howard
marks for example he's not really a this
is the guy who manages something like
160 billion dollars the overseas needs
this this very brilliant cerebral guy
he's not a great Optimist or Visionary
he doesn't look at the future and think
everything's going to be golden so he's
kind of a pessimist he ended up
investing in things like distressed debt
in in the debt of companies that were
were in trouble because there's a
contract there and you actually knew
what what you'd get and so there's a
degree of predictability
whereas if he were a venture capitalist
for example he was just betting on hot
tech companies that might one day live
up to these Blue Sky dreamy Promises of
the the salesman behind them that would
totally not suit his character
and so I think part of the trick
is to look at yourself really
really honestly with self-awareness and
say
what am I built
to do in life like what game can I
actually play that I'll be successful at
and
Buffett often talks about the importance
of saying no
to almost everything the he just he he
just sticks with what he's good at and
his way of operating and his way of
thinking and so I think there's a lot to
unpack and discuss in that idea but that
that to me has had a really profound
effect because I start to think for
example like people people will say oh
you're a writer you should do a substant
newsletter and I'm like yeah but I'm
slow and ponderous and and I think and
I'm kind of obsessive and obsessively
perfectionist may take a long time the
last thing I should be doing is pumping
out material I should be I should be
trying to create something that's kind
of beautiful and deeply thought through
and well honed and well crafted and so
it's a slow game and so for me to say I
I'm not going to be one of those people
like um
uh like like Lee Child right who pumps
out a novel once a year it's like if I
can write three more books five more
books in the course of a long life that
would be a Triumph and so I think for
all of your listeners this doesn't just
apply to investing it applies to every
area of life to think what am I
optimized for what like stick to games
that you can win and that doesn't mean
you don't want to get better at things
that you're not good at but I think if
you if you look back at what it was like
being at school like I have kids right I
have a uh 23 year old son who's about to
turn 24 on a 21 year old daughter and so
much of that time at school particularly
if my daughter was focused on the things
that she wasn't good at like math like
um sort of remedial stuff to get you up
to up to uh an acceptable level at
something you were always going to be
kind of crap at yeah and she's
incredibly talented and a wonderful
writer and writes music beautifully and
teaches herself new instruments and she
was spending so much time on the things
that she wasn't good at
that she didn't actually have time to to
do the stuff that she was good at and
she you know she would she would go sing
in Carnegie Hall with like Bruce
Springsteen and sting and stuff like
that I mean you know she was singing at
an amazing level but but she never could
be in the choir at school or anything
like that or even have time for music
lessons because you're busy doing math
yeah and trying to catch up with math
and so once you are an adult I think you
really want to focus a lot on saying
this is what I'm built for this is the
game I'm gonna win and and with
investing one of the things you want to
do is say am I built to outperform the
market am I built to have extraordinary
returns do I have the emotional wiring
of these great investors do I have the
interest and am I obsessive enough and
one of the things I came to the
conclusion about after spending so much
time with these people is I'm actually
not built that way I'm much more fearful
I'm much more anxious than the best
investors and
so it's very hard for me to outperform I
have certain characteristics that are
really good as an investor like like I'm
extremely patient it's I mean I know you
recently interviewed my friend guy Speer
I've been investing with guy spear for
more than 20 years that that's a
tremendous advantage to have that
patience but I I don't want to sit
around reading annual reports and stuff
like that I can't think of anything more
tedious but I was I was going to ask you
about that actually
um regarding you know uh was it was it
just a lack of maybe innate
wiring that made you not want to
become an investor or was it a matter of
listen I don't want to put 40 hours per
week plus into reading annual reports so
I was very curious to
um I mean look at look at the bookshelf
behind me in this I assume this is just
a video a non-audio thing but I mean
look if I if I turn this here right so
these are books that I'm sort of working
on at the moment so at the top there
there are three book two books that came
yesterday one of them is called The Way
of the bodhisattva and one of them is
called Vivid awareness and then there's
one called profound Simplicity and the
naked now which is a sort of uh you know
in the surrender experiment and I am
that and the collected works of Ramana
mahashi I mean these are mainly
spiritual things or philosophical or
historical or I mean they're weird and
so I had three books like that arrived
yesterday my wife opens the package from
Amazon and she's like more Buddhist crap
basically you know I she didn't really
put it by like that but that was the
subtext and and I'm not a Buddhist I
just study this stuff obsessively and
I'm really interested in it so I I think
you
you need
you need to harness your own craziness
in life your own particular form of
video secrecy so for me
I may not have the patience to sit
around reading annual reports but I can
spend
five months on that chapter on Nick's
sleep getting it to a point where
there's no word that I would change and
so there's a degree of absolute
obsessiveness that makes no sense at all
rationally I sometimes wondered if my
obsessiveness in perfecting a sentence
as much as I could was actually a form
of self-soothing that in a in a crazy
world where we don't control that much I
could sit at my desk and I could go over
a sentence or a paragraph to a point
where it felt perfect to me it kind of
reflected what was going on in my mind
um the sort of difficult thought in a
perfect way so there was a there was a
degree of of craziness and self-soothing
that you know and then also you know I
studied English literature at Oxford and
I went to Columbia journalism school and
I spent the last
50 years reading obsessively so just
kind of plays to my strengths it's my
game and
I love interviewing people and talking
and so and I'm always trying to figure
out kind of the meaning of life and
what's going on so so writing a book
like this just played to my strengths to
a ridiculous degree although I did miss
my deadline by two years so in that
sense it didn't
um and so so yeah I I think I think one
of the things that's really distinctive
about the greatest investors and
probably the people who are the greatest
at everything is they're self-aware
enough that they say
yeah I'm not going to play that game
that's not one that suits my talents
it's not one that suits my temperament
and then
you want to focus really obsessively on
that area that is important to you
and I think I I read a lot about
um high performance habits in the book
and one of one of the things that I
think is very valuable that that these
guys do that I think we can apply in any
area of Our Lives is they remove a lot
of complexity from their life so they
it's not just that you're focusing on
the game that you can win
it's that then you remove a lot of this
other complexity and noise from your
life so if you think about how
superficial and and
has superficial and narrow well actually
Narrows the wrong word how superficial
most of our lives are right we're we're
constantly being dinged by notifications
I'm obsessed with things like Twitter
and uh you know because it's important
as a writer right you're kind of
building a tribe and you're sharing your
ideas but so you have this very shallow
life where you're not in a pejorative
kind of critical way but it's just like
you're responding constantly to emails
text messages Twitter notifications
LinkedIn messages and
so there's a lot of busyness without
much depth and I think one of the
superpowers in life that I see in a lot
of the most successful investors is this
ability to go kind of narrow and deep
and so you remove all of the complexity
and then you find this area where you
have what buff it would call your circle
of competence and you keep expanding
that Circle of confidence so if if for
example you you don't understand tech
stocks you start to study technology you
start to study cryptocurrencies because
you're like well it's a new thing I
can't just deny that it exists
um so you need to expand your your
circle of competence but at the same
time you're going really deep and
removing a lot of that unnecessary noise
and unnecessary complexity and also
unnecessary short-termism so if you
think about how short-term most of our
lives are
it's not just the information we consume
it's also
it's everything really right Everything
Is On Demand right you have infinite TV
on demand infinite infinite
um Infinite porn infinite food infinite
music everything is available right now
and so this is one of the things I wrote
about in writing about
um Nick sleep and his partner K sakaria
is that part of their gift part of their
advantage both in investing and life is
their ability to think long term and to
defer gratification and so while
everyone else is going shallow and short
term and kind of widespread and Scatter
shot that they would say okay we're
going to focus on information that has a
long shelf life for example so they
would say
we don't we don't really care about the
daily news or we don't care about what
they dismissively called Wiggle guessing
in terms of stocks or most people are
focusing on this and they're like yeah
but this went up here and this happened
today and all the nonsense that you see
on CNBC right where it's like
um uh projections about what's going to
happen today because of this it's just
noise and so the ability to tune out
noise and focus on what actually matters
becomes a superpower both in investing
in life and so what what Nick sleep
would do is he would say for example
um
let's think about what would make a
business really successful and so you
look at something like Amazon or Costco
and he would say and both of which he's
made a fortune on I mean he invested in
in Amazon incredibly early in his owned
up exactly 16 17 18 years and it's it's
the majority of his own personal
portfolio is in it and so
he would say okay well
what's what's a desirable destination
for a business like this and so you'd
say well okay so they need to uh here
for it to become what Bezos says it
could become
that that that would be like this okay
so what are the inputs that will get it
to be there
um how do they need to treat their
customers how do they need to handle
Logistics how do they how do they need
to handle returns how do they need to
drive down prices how do they need to
treat their employees are they doing
these things and so they would call this
destination analysis so you focus on the
destination a desirable destination then
you work backwards so that's a very
different way of thinking than everyone
who's doing this wiggle guessing just
listening to all this noise and reacting
here's Nick saying no let me think about
the desirable destination and are they
doing what will get they get them there
5 10 15 20 years and the beauty of this
is that you can apply it to your own
career and your own life as well so you
can say okay if I want to be
successful and financially independent
and secure so I don't have to take in
orders from any idiotic boss who I don't
like or or work in a job that I dislike
what am I going to have to do what does
that desirable destination look like and
then let me work backwards so then if
you think about the inputs to get you
there like well so I better live within
my means I've had to save aggressively
uh I better invest intelligently I
better try to keep my investing expenses
low so if if my expenses on brokerage
trades or high fees from funds heat away
at my returns I'm not going to reach
that desirable destination of being
financially independent and secure and
not beholden to anyone and not
vulnerable if it's the fan and the world
goes through a difficult recession or a
war or something like that and so just
that that that simple filter of thinking
about destination long-term destination
how to get there is so powerful and it's
so different from the kind of the kind
of short-termism and reactiveness of
most people's approach to life so what
I'm trying to do is highlight some of
these principles that work in investing
in life so that at least once you
understand that okay so you're I'm still
going to be dinged by Twitter
notifications and the like and and I'm
still going to be
um short-term and I'm still I'm still
subject to all these dopamine hits like
yeah I'll have another piece of toast
with honey on it and and an extra donut
or whatever
um
but at least I'll be at least I'll
understand what the game is at least
I'll understand that the more I push
things towards long-term decisions
um towards focusing on what will get me
to a good destination the more of a
competitive Advantage I have both in
investing and life
most people just don't know they don't
know that these principles are important
yeah and it's it's very much
um you know listening to you speak right
now reading your book it it just it
instantly tied to just being uh as
Naseem taleb says anti-fragile right
yeah 20 and 30 year olds would be
watching this for the most part and you
know so many people in the workforce in
the marketplace just feel like they
don't have an edge they it's it's an age
of uncertainty and and like you said
these these instant dopamine hits of get
anything you want is making it even
harder than ever but for those who can
tap into finding their self-awareness
whether that is
um I'm curious to hear how maybe you do
this and what you've seen other
investors do and how they tap into that
reflective process I know some meditate
I think it was John Templeton who would
go in the ocean and do exercises and if
that was a reflective process for him so
um I think people having maybe an
internal even if it's 30 minutes a day
I'm curious to know uh if you have a
process and
um that that you find works really well
for you and this is really important for
me because as you can probably tell
already Jeremy I have a scattered mind
my mind's all over the place my you know
my bookshelf looks like it's going to
collapsed right that's a that's a pretty
good um representation
uh it's it's sort of I mean it's kind of
a glorious disaster and so
um which is a yeah it's a bit like it's
a it's a bit like the state of my my
brain and so so I think a lot about how
do you how do you find Equanimity and
peace within the chaos
of the world and and this is a
this is a really important question
because
it really affects everything from the
way you invest to the way you treat your
um your parents your kids your husband
or wife your boyfriend your girlfriend
your co-workers I mean if you're
if you're emotionally flooded you make
crap decisions if you're stressed you
make crap decisions I I have a friend
who I write about in the book I
um who's
um an expert on the brain Ken
schubenstein who who Not only was a
terrific investor who taught the
advanced investment research course at
Columbia for many years but um also now
is uh is a neurologist uh so he's
actually treating people's brains he's
obsessed with the subject of the brain
and one thing that he said to me is
when you're in various States like being
hungry angry lonely tired in pain or
stressed you make terrible decisions
you're you're kind of primed to make
terrible decisions so just being aware
that your decision making about your
future about how to talk to your boss
about how to talk to your employee about
how to talk to your your partner your
kid your dog whatever or what investment
to make that your your physiological
state is actually going to affect you
that's a really profound realization so
one of the most important things you
want to do both in investing in life is
to take control over your inner life and
so
we don't really have control over what's
going to happen in Ukraine we don't have
control over inflation
we don't have control of whether the
Market's going up or not anyone who
pretends that they can even predict
whether the market is going up or what
inflation is going to be or where war is
going to break out is either fooling you
or fooling themselves and
so these are things we don't have
control over and so what you want to
focus on is the stuff that you do
control like like
am I able to create emotional Equanimity
Within
within the chaos so I mean literally I
have I have a posted on my on my wall
here I have a lot of posts that's on my
wall one of them
um to something from a a great Buddhist
teacher called Sophia who talks about
um
just sitting within the fluidity without
judgment and so that's something that's
an idea from meditation where you're
just you're just sitting there comedy
with everything going on you're just
sitting there and you're not judging
you're not saying I hate this I feel so
stressed I need to change this I I'm so
anxious you're watching your anxiety and
you're watching your fear and you're
watching you're upset I had someone
cancel an interview on the last minute
yesterday and I meditated after its own
sitting there and I I think the phrase
that came to my mind is a terrible
phrases something like
um uh I'm an afterthought
um uh eating Crumbs from from the the
tape from the the table of Great Men or
something it was a terrible image that
came up in this sort of Silence sitting
you're like oh wow all right really
that's how you feel at the moment like
that that irrelevant and that much of a
schmuck and a loser because this guy
just canceled the interview like okay
and so what this guy is certainly would
say is that that you would do what he
calls handshake practice so when
something like that comes up that kind
of Despair or self-loathing or sadness
or sense of inadequacy
you don't suppress it you don't repress
it
you look at it and you handshake it and
you say hi okay yep welcome okay yeah
that too yeah I feel that I feel that
sadness and that sense of
um
and then and then you kind of laugh at
it right because you're like wow really
is it that and he also says this
wonderful thing because he often says um
uh one of one of his kind of mantras it
which my my son who likes certain room
share as well enjoys is who cares so
what and so and he says if if that's not
spiritual life for you you can add on to
your cares so you say um who cares so
what in this Tibetan Tibetan accent that
he has and so
so you watch this stuff as it arises you
see what you're subject to the emotions
that you're subject to whether it's fear
anger or jealousy or or hatred or
sadness or depression or worry or
whatever it is you see it arise and
instead of immediately fleeing from it
you
you kind of
you welcome it but you don't you don't
kind of fall into oh my God yeah I've
got to chase after this anxiety or this
fear or this despair you're just like
okay yeah that's it hi hi welcome to the
party
and and what this guy David Hawkins who
I spent a lot of time studying would say
he wrote a book called Letting Go the
thing is very important book I I
definitely
um draw your listeners attention to
chapter two of that which discusses this
this mechanism of Letting Go what he
says is that the resistance to these
emotions is what gets us in trouble it's
it's
when these negative thought patterns
come up or these negatives not even the
right word but there's there's not very
helpful thought patterns like despair or
sadness or anger or whatever all of
these things that we all have we all
have our own particular flavor of of uh
of of of of this stuff
um his is the problem is often that we
suppress it we repress it we project it
on to other people so it may be so for
example I could easily get myself into a
state where I was so pissed off at the
guy who had canceled at the last minute
after I'd spent my entire Sunday
preparing for this interview working
till like midnight and stuff
um
uh not spending time with my wife as a
result only to have the interview cancel
uh I could be projecting my sense of of
inadequacy
um and irrelevance
um on this guy and get myself into a
frenzy of anger but instead if I'm
watching it
then I can be like okay yep and then you
can also let it go and so you can kind
of surrender it and so it depends
whether you have spiritual beliefs or
anything like that but I I think you can
I think there's deep wisdom in surrender
in sort of saying
all right I I don't know what do I do
about my sense of self-loathing and
inadequacy I don't know it comes from
childhood it comes from all the ways in
which we were inadequate as kids or that
we disappointed our parents or we
disappointed our school teachers or and
it's just there it just is and so you
just say all right I Surrender that give
that to the universe or to to the
Creator or to you know my ancestors or
righteous people who existed or Jesus or
Buddha or I mean I'm Jewish and and and
I studied Kabbalah mainly uh sort of my
yeah and so they're all of these
righteous figures throughout history
um people who have great catalysts so
you could literally just say okay I
Surrender this to them but it doesn't
matter to the universe but just that act
of being aware of what's coming up and
letting go of it I think is hugely
hugely helpful I there's there's also a
very useful book that I would recommend
to your listeners called The Surrender
experiment which is a um I think it's on
my pile here which is by someone called
Michael Singer and he talks about
something very similar
um
and he's he's someone he was very
brilliant guy
um intellectually very brilliant who at
a certain point just decided I'm going
to start ignoring the voice inside my
head whatever Mickey singer wants me to
do and he's going to see what the
universe is kind of asking me to do in
this situation and I'm just going to
surrender to it and so he'd buy this
property and fart her and he suddenly
discovers he looked at he's like wait
someone's building building a house on
my property what the hell and he does
that and this woman says to him yeah I
wanted to attend your meditations that
you do on Saturday and so
I decided to build something on your on
your property so he's like this is
outraged right and then he's thinking
well maybe that's what the universe
wants me to do and so he's like okay
I'll come help you and so he goes and
helps her build on his on his property
and so all of these extraordinary things
happened here as he surrenders his own
his own sense of like this is how it
must be and so this is this is just one
way of approaching these issues but I I
think you've got to think about
where you're going to get your
Equanimity how you're going to deal with
these negative emotions the the fear the
uncertainty and so I think one of the
things one of the most helpful things
that I learned from this process of
spending so much time into and great
investors was that it's it's not a side
issue to focus on your inner landscape
it's Central and and Guy spear who I
know you interviewed once said to me I
helped him write his book the
educational value investor which I think
is very much worth reading for any of
your listeners he he had this wonderful
image for me once where he said that
when he moved from New York where I live
to to Zurich
um to this kind of slightly Bland very
pleasant neighborhood in Zurich he said
it was very quiet and it was great
because his mind is all over the place
like mine possibly even worse than mine
and he said uh although he might dispute
that uh but if he's listened this far
he'll get distracted off and do
something else anyway so we won't hear
this bit but he said he said to me you
you want your mind to be like a Quiet
Pond like a calm pond
so that when you throw a stone in it you
can actually see the Ripples and so if
you think about that image if I have
something like this canceled interview
yesterday or if the market is crashing
um and I'm calm enough to see oh okay
there's fear there's anxiety Then I'm
less likely to be hijacked by it I'm
more likely to be able to make a good
decision and also if I if I think about
what my friend Ken schubenstein the
neurologist who taught at Columbia
business school would say you know that
you're going to be able to get back to a
base State sooner or later like you're
when you're a hungry angry lonely tired
and pain stressed and you're getting
flooded you know that's not gonna last
and so during those periods you just
want to slow things down and just say
okay well I'm not going to make a really
huge decision in this moment it's it's
like I remember when I was a teenager
um some girl I was dating did something
I kind of remember what that broke my
heart matter is absolutely miserable and
I was saying exactly the opposite of
what I should say you know it's one of
those things where you're like I'm not
going to say this and then you
immediately say uh the worst thing and
so you know and so you destroy these
relationships when you're young because
because you just didn't have control
over your tongue you know to say yeah
maybe maybe this is not the right moment
to have the argument with my boss or my
or or my wife or parent or something and
so
just knowing the degree to which life
isn't in a game but investing isn't in a
game and uh anything being a good
employee being a good friend and so
meditation is key but I would also say
exercise to a ridiculous extent it's key
and and I'm sort of embarrassed to say
this because we all know about the many
benefits of exercise but when when covet
started I was thinking okay this is very
much a way that the great investors
would think
um not not that I'm a great investor I I
was thinking okay so what can I control
and what can't I control
I can't control
the fact that
um
there's this there's this new disease
that none of us really understand and
that can mutate
I can't control the mutations I can't
control public policy I can't control
the politicization of public policy West
people are like not willing to wear
masks or
um so I can't control other people's
behavior what can I control well I can
control social distancing I can control
whether I wear a mask I can control
whether I get vaccinated when the
vaccines come along and I'm not saying
this in any political way I'm just
thinking what are the things I can
control and I can control my own weight
and my own Fitness because we know that
being very heavy and unhealthy is a
precondition for lots of illness so so
we now know much more clearly that it's
also it also makes you much more
vulnerable to covert but what I was
thinking then is well I don't know how
serious covet is but I can see the stats
on heart disease and high blood pressure
and cancer and all of these things and I
know and stroke and I can see that if I
take control of exercising in my diet
um which is very difficult for me
because I'm sedentary I'm lazy and like
to sit and read
um and not move
um I know that I stack the odds in my
favor over successful outcome of of
getting to a decent destination and so
what I did is right at the start of
covet we we bought a Peloton and and and
I've probably done 700 rides since then
in over two years and that for me is an
extraordinary thing so so I took control
of my health and fitness to some degree
not not perfectly I mean I still didn't
bother to stretch much or do weights or
any of the other things I know are good
for me
um
but I tilted the odds in my favor and
controlled what I could control and the
joke is that after all of these decades
full of existential angst and worry
about well and deep thoughts about life
I found that I just became happier when
I exercised that it just has this
ridiculously powerful impact on on your
on your mind and your emotions and so
again just think about
think about how you're going to create
internal Equanimity because that's what
you can control and so you control your
health you control your mental health
you're playing the cards that you've
been dealt as well as possible and then
all of the other stuff kind of radiates
out from that if there's a calm Center
think about how much better your your
decision making is going to be
um how much better your relationships
will be because you're just more decent
to people because you're not torpedoed
by stress and when I think about the
times when I was horrible to my children
it was almost always because I was
really stressed you know I'd be I'd be
trying to finish a chapter that was
killing me and I couldn't understand it
and and the everything was going badly I
knew I was way behind on my deadline
um and my son uh Henry who I loved it
was a wonderful wonderful human being
would be playing guitar and and singing
outside my room
stop and and he'd be like what do you
mean and and you know and so it was my
stress and his stress multiplied and
when I when I went out
and I was sort of in a better mood
um you'd be like uh do you think he
could hold it just like half an hour
just wrestling with this lost paragraph
and you'd be like oh okay sure sure
um and so this stuff sounds so stupid
and so platitudinous and so banal and so
obvious that most of us don't really
think about it but I I just think you
want to spend an enormous amount of time
thinking about how how to how to create
inner peace and calm whether it's
through
prayer meditation exercise
um walking in the woods uh it and it's
swimming it's different for each of us
and and so again it's not about it's not
about playing somebody else's game it's
about finding what works for you
right and and you even said in the book
for for people who know they need to
exercise more right and covid definitely
set back almost everyone in terms of
exercise
um you laid out in the book of one of
the investors I can't remember his name
right now at the top of my head but just
run five minutes a day
yeah Tom Gainer run five minutes a day
and then next week Run 10 minutes a day
yeah and and then just start to compound
and get one percent better every day
with these little actions and
um I guess whatever you're compounding
in life by by focusing on the internal
game and exercise and relationships
you're just increasing longevity allows
you to come compound your whether it's
investing or your career or Goodwill
um it's it's amazing what can happen and
I'm realizing that
um as time goes on and so making sure
our I'm compounding the right things
that matter to me and hopefully other
people compounding the things that
matter to the dumb and figuring that out
and saying no kind of going back to what
you said saying no to compounding things
that don't matter to you
I think could be
um a big thing and when you when you're
in your 20s it's really hard to say no
because you need that opportunity right
as you get older it's easier but a lot
of the great investors in your book they
it's like they knew their Dharma at a
you had a very young age
um and I guess they did this internal
game and we're lucky to find it or they
just knew how to find that early on in
life
yeah and what what you what you've said
about compounding is very profound that
it's and it makes me really happy that
you've internalized this idea to such an
extent that it's it's thinking about
compounding in multiple ways so usually
people think about compounding wealth
um
how am I going to compound money in the
stock markets and and so one of the
great lessons that I learned from guy
steer who we mentioned before is this
idea of compounding Goodwill and it
sounds really trite like most of these
truths they sound kind of banal
um but the idea of compounding Goodwill
turns out to be one of the most powerful
lessons I've learned in life so so
if you just start by being nice and
decent to people and treating people
respectfully and and trying to be kind I
mean we all screw up constantly I I
don't want to set myself up it's any
sort of there's any sort of Saint I've
done all sorts of crappy things
um
but
if you know that that's a goal
and you know that it's a benefit and
you've started early
what's really striking about these good
habits like compounding Goodwill
behaving behaving decently to people is
that the benefits don't seem that
striking in the short term so once in a
while
you
you do something in the short term where
you're nice to someone and you see an
immediate payoff and you're like that's
weird like this thing happened and then
this thing happened and that's weird but
part of what's tricky about life when
you're in your 20s I think is
is that you don't have the data points
you don't have the evidence to say oh
wow that really worked and so there's
kind of this leap of faith where you're
like well I'll try to be less of a prick
and and you're like I don't know is that
a good idea or not because actually we
know like there's actually a sense that
maybe it's kind of naive to be decent
and ethical and moral and kind like
maybe maybe if you're
in the workplace and it's super
competitive maybe you have an advantage
being sharp elbowed and unpleasant and
and nobody really tells you the rules of
the game and so early on in my life I
think I I you know I was a journalist I
was working in places like Forbes and
Time Magazine this is a very rapacious
Cutthroat competitive places with lots
of really smart people pushing for space
in the magazine trying to get higher on
on the Masthead and it was and it was a
difficult business that was becoming
smaller because it was challenged by the
internet and so it's very easy to
internalize the idea that no I need to
take care of myself and stand up for
myself and be a snake and be Sharp and
and what I
what I gradually have come to believe
and I I may be wrong and it's and I
think you have to be true to yourself
I think there's an overwhelming
competitive advantage that comes from
being consistently decent over time and
what you discover
this is something that Tom Gainer
mentions in the book where he he says
one of his advantages is I'm a nice guy
and he says there are so many people who
wish me well who are reaching out to
help me uh and I saw this recently I
organized a private event where it was
just for about 35 people at an
investment firm in New York and I asked
Tom Gainer who's CEO of co-ceo of a
fortune 400 company who manages like 19
000 people or something like that in 20
20 private companies and it was very
important very successful guy managed
over 20 billion dollars I think I said
would you come and speak there's nothing
in it for him and he takes a train for
six hours from Virginia to New York and
spends the night and comes and talks for
an hour I interviewed him at this event
just kind just incredibly kind but think
about that kind of behavior compounded
over decades think about all of the
people who wish Tom well because of the
way he behaves and so when Tom's looking
to hire someone or when
um when he's going through a difficult
period people are going to be supportive
of him and
I think it's much like things like
exercise and meditation we don't you see
a bit of the benefit on the day that you
exercise or on the day that you meditate
maybe maybe you feel that much less
stressed or that or or that much more
self-righteous because you did something
good or whatever but it's not like
you're thinner or you know because you
exercised or are you suddenly look
incredibly handsome or uh I mean in your
case maybe but it might be still a
challenge but if you meditate
for 10 12 minutes a day
for five ten years two years 20 years it
becomes an overwhelming advantage and I
I see this there's a there's a famous
right track I call Dan Goldman who wrote
this book on EQ on emotional
intelligence that's that sold one five
million copies over the years
and I've become friends with him and
he's I I don't see him a great deal but
he's someone who's meditated for 40 50
years
I tell you when you're in his presence
you see someone who's deeply calm and
deeply present and when I look at that
he's he's older than I am and I look at
him and I think that's what I want to be
when I grow up he's not only a really
successful writer
but he's very deeply present and very
deeply calm and so you see the benefits
of these behaviors compounding over
decades and so I think
if there's a takeaway here for for our
listeners again it's to think about the
destination think about what you want to
become the type of person you want to be
in terms of your health in terms of your
career in terms of your relationships in
terms of your finances your financial
Independence and then work backwards and
think about what's going to get me there
what are the inputs and then pick a
handful of habits to use Tom gainer's
phrase which I find incredibly helpful
habits that are directionally correct so
they don't have to be optimal you don't
have to say
um you know it's like look if you looked
at my arms they're like pathetically
thin and you know I know that I should
be doing weights I know that it's
important and I used to do it but I I
sort of stopped when when we left our
gym during covert and it used the excuse
not to start again but at least I'm
directionally correct in the fact that
I'm exercising probably 150 to 200
minutes a week which is a really good
amount to exercise I think based on what
I've learned
from my crappy rudimentary study of this
stuff so it's a directionally correct
habit
I don't meditate every day but I try to
meditate pretty consistently
um it's directionally correct
um I have a morning connection I call it
where I do a few prayers from
um the capitalistic prayer but to put my
mind in a particular place that I do
probably six times a week something like
that and and one of the things that
you're doing
is
you're focusing on other people
and so you're getting out of your own
head and you're also there are things
like there's a there's a I'm not in any
way trying to be a proselytizer I mean
I've I've gone through all of the phase
I've been and atheist I've been agnostic
and I've become increasingly spiritual
as I'm older so you so you know that I'm
wrong at some point you know like I've
had all the positions so you know I've
been wrong but
um one of one of the prayers for example
has the Hebrew word and that which means
troops you've set over and over again it
re recurs and and so one of the things
you're you're asking I mean I did it
this morning literally I'm saying please
bless me with the attribute of Truth and
truthfulness and that's just the
Consciousness behind it so then when I'm
coming to do an interview like this I'm
thinking
well is this about trying to sell books
and trying to puff up my ego and trying
to be self-important or is it like no
let me try to be a conduit for truth in
some way to pass on information Insight
that's helpful and that's true and I
don't really know whether what we're
saying is true but just to just to have
the desire to be a conduit for truth and
for uh something that's gonna you know
shift the direction of the world a
little bit in in the direction of Truth
and kindness and mercy and compassion
and all of these virtues so so this is
one of the things that I'm I'm doing
every morning that again it's deeply
personal I'm not in any way trying to
proselytize but before I start I'm like
let me give strength to love Mercy
kindness compassion truth Oneness and
I would have rolled my eyes at this 20
years ago I would have looked myself and
been like what a [ __ ] not only a [ __ ]
and a dupe and full of wishful thinking
but a proselytizing [ __ ] do full of
wishful thinking and now I think well
I've probably done this for 13 14 years
at this point and so I can actually see
that I rewired my brain
but at a certain point when you keep
when you keep pounding in the same
message whether it's through prayer or
meditation or or reading the same texts
the whole time or affirmations anything
you want to do you're rewiring your
brain so if your default position is to
be anxious or self-pitying or to feel
like a victim and instead you say
this is something I learned from Arnold
Vandenberg who's the last the last
person I write about in the book is in
many ways the most inspiring person in
the book because he transformed his life
after going through the Holocaust
um he had every reason to feel like a
victim and to be full of rage and anger
he was he had 39 members of his family
died in Holocaust and his uh you know he
was his father used to beat him up and
his uh he was in an orphanage when he
was a kid and his uh uh his first wife
left him for another man I mean he had
so many things go wrong and he barely
made it through high school and
everyone's already had brain damage
um what he did is
he totally transformed his inner
landscape and so partly he did it by
hypnotizing himself but partly he did it
through affirmations and so when he was
full of Rage he would literally be
saying no no I'm a loving person who
just say to himself over and over again
I'm a loving person so so if I remind
myself constantly that I want to be a
conduit for truth
um I I
or if I want to be I just want to be
kinda
um so even though I keep screwing up and
I keep doing stupid self-destructive
things or I keep behaving in a way that
I'm kind of ashamed of or whatever but
if I keep coming back to that true north
of saying let me just try to be kinda
um that's such a that that simple
understanding
is so overwhelmingly powerful if you
keep at it I mean if you
so it's so it's knowing what's important
to you so I wrote about this in the
first chapter of the book right where I
wrote about Montage power bright it's a
great cloner he he copies what other
people have figured out who are smarter
than him wiser than him older than him
like Buffett and manga who become
mentors to him and he says okay so what
can I learn from these people and then
manga says take a simple idea and take
it seriously so one of the things that
that monishes learned is
I'm going to be truthful because partly
what happened is he studied David
Hawkins the guy we talked about before
um who wrote that book letting go and
Hawkins wrote a very important book
called power versus force that I really
encouraged our listeners to to read and
monish gets the idea from that book I'm
just going to tell the truth because if
I tell the truth it kind of resonates at
a higher level and people will sense
whether I'm lying or telling the truth
and it's going to draw better people
into my life and it's worked
astonishingly well for me
I ended up concluding in that chapter
yeah I want to be more truthful but I
thought well I think there's tremendous
power in cloning this idea of focusing
on one great virtue that you come back
to again and again
and I think truth is really important
being truthful is really important not
being a liar is important but for me and
maybe this is just my excuse I can get
away with being a liar more
um I think kindness
is probably the one that trumps
everything for me and so I think if I
can be directionally correct I was the
next you know 20 30 40 years however
long I have uh you know God God willing
it's not like just three months because
I've got a lot of work to do on this
front
um
um if I can focus on becoming Kinder and
consistently come back to that true
north then you can look and you can say
all right so so I can still be full of
annoyance at the guy who canceled on me
yesterday
um or self-pity or whatever but it's
okay because now I'm calm again now I've
looked at what came up I've looked at my
annoyance I've looked at my sense that
I'm just picking off Crumbs from the
table of Great Men uh the scraps from
the table of Great Men I'm like yeah
okay but let me let me just focus on
trying to be kinda trying to be more
decent trying to be more loving and um
and that's directionally correct for me
is more likely to get me
to the end point of having really great
relationships loving relationships and
um
and and I do think this idea of
compounding Goodwill turns out to be
professionally very powerful as well so
it's so
you know so you can find you can find
self-interested reasons for behaving
kindly and decently as well you can
justify it because people people trust
you and so you're going to work with
better people because they trust you I
mean you look at Buffett amonga part of
their advantage is that they're
surrounded by really high quality people
who want to be in that orbit it's
because they've been honest they're not
just it's not just because they're
really smart I mean if you if you were
choosing who to do a deal with you do it
yeah right and I know um the guy was
telling me that Warren Buffett sends
Christmas cards yeah to a lot of
individuals and how much a simple act
yeah just like that can make a huge
difference in someone's life it's not
like you have to do something
extravagant to change someone's life
yeah I had this discussion I I started a
new podcast recently and there's a so
I've been interviewing people like Ray
dalio and and Howard Marx and Joe
Greenblatt so it's amazing oh thanks
it's got the same name it's Rachel White
your podcast and there's an episode
coming up with um aswith the motoran
who's a famous NYU Professor who's an
expert on valuation
and it hasn't come out yet and I haven't
edited yet there's a point in it I think
about two-thirds of the way through this
long conversation
where he talks about
um these little acts of kindness
and he says something that literally it
stopped me in my track so you'll hear in
the interview right I say what you said
just stopped me on my tracks because
he's talking about
um sometimes when you're interviewing
some of you interviewing somebody you
hear something that you're like oh
that's deep truth like what I just heard
that's deep truth and sometimes it
actually brings you up in chills because
you realize it's true and he was talking
I think he mentioned somebody in Iran
who had written to him and he he gets
something like 300 emails a day and he
tries to respond and he tries to help
people despite this constant Cascade of
stuff coming to him and so even if it's
20 seconds he'll say go look at this go
look at this maybe contact this person
that sort of thing and someone had
written to him I think and said that
response that you gave me totally and
awfully transformed my life like like I
think this guy left Iran ended up
becoming a money manager stuff like
something like that I'm gobbling this
but that idea these little actions can
change the world and so so you look at
Buffett
um Buffett Buffett reads guy's annual
report and sends him a note a few months
ago saying how much he liked his annual
report nothing in it for Buffett to do
that it's just it's just you know this
90 something year old guy spreading
goodwill because he can being kind
because he can and and maybe knowing
that his life is better if that's how he
behaves because
it's not just that people like you more
and respect you more which which is good
for your ego and maybe it's good for
your business and stuff like that you
have more self-respect if you behave in
a good way I I remember I used to it was
so embarrassing thing to say
um I sometimes find now when I'm passing
a mirror I look at myself and I smile
I'm like God I never used to do that and
just looking at yourself and being
closer to liking yourself because you
behave better uh and I've still got a
long way to go but that's an enormous
benefit and so I I write about this a
bit in the epilogue of the book I'm
trying to talk about what actually
constitutes a successful and Abundant
Life and it's it's not about
wealth maximization you you do
I I don't in any way diminish the
importance of money because I I think
there's nothing worse well there are
many things worse but but it's pretty
crappy to have that fear of not having
enough money to feel that you're trapped
and to feel that kind of corrosive worry
that you're not going to be able to pay
the next bill you're not going to be
able to to take care of your kids or
um that's a horrible feeling no I I
don't think anyone anyone wants to go
through that so I'm I'm not in any way
diminishing the importance of having
money so that you can be financially
independent and free so that you can do
the job that you want go on the trips
that you want live in a nice home
um it's not about being flashy or
anything like that but but to have that
kind of Independence that kind of
freedom to to say no to projects that
you don't want to do things like that
that's incredibly valuable but you don't
want to fall into the delusion of
thinking that money power
Fame success reputation that all of
these things are going to make you happy
because they're so um they're so fragile
and superficial and so this is one of
the things that I if if any of your
listeners do read the book I'd really
draw your attention to that epilogue
because because when you when you're
choosing the destination you want in
life you don't want to spend 50 years
chasing after the wrong thing and be and
and this is one reason why a lot of
middle-aged people like me ended up
um as I did in my 40s I'm now 53 in my
40s I had a sort of existential crisis
where suddenly you're like oh my God I
did all of these things to become
successful
and I'm miserable and and so you know I
I mean I became the editor of the
international editions of time and I was
sort of you know flying around feeling
self-important interviewing presidents
and prime ministers and then I get laid
off and then suddenly like well so it
wasn't no I I you know all of the all of
the respect and stuff I got where I
could go interview the British prime
minister or the Indian prime minister or
something you know it's all gone and so
that was really fragile and so knowing
that it's not about the wealth the
reputation the power stuff like that
it's actually the things like
building powerful relationships
um again seems like a platitude but but
you know Ed Thorpe this guy right about
who's I describes the greatest game
player in the history of investing
there's a guy who he figured out how to
count cards right he's the guy who
invented that whole thing figured out
how to beat the casino roulette even uh
I mean just the brilliant brilliant guy
when I talked to him about how to
approach The Game of Life if you treated
Life as a game that you were trying to
crack in the same way that he cracked
the game of roulette or the game of
blackjack or the game of managing hedge
fund he said well look the the most
important thing is who you spend your
time with
and it's so obvious but if you think
about it then you're like oh so why
don't I try to get better people into my
life and so how am I going to get better
people into my life well I'm going to
have to behave decently because why
would good quality people want to be in
my life if I suck and so
just having just it's it's a bit like
the Deferred gratification question that
we discussed before with Nick sleep it's
not that you're gonna
bat perfectly it's that at least you
know that's the game at least you want
to be less superficial at least you want
to be deferring gratification and not
going for the quick hit of dopamine
at least you know that you want to be
trying to become kinda you know that you
want to try to become more truthful
um you want to try to get better people
in your life
um and not just chase after money and
fame and power and all of these things
and so just knowing
knowing what what the playground is in
which you're playing knowing what the
game is is a huge Head Start and so that
that that's part of what I'm trying to
Define in writing the book and
interviewing all of these people is to
say oh that's what works that's that's
this is how the smartest people alive
the most practical smartest most
pragmatic people alive this is what they
figured out about what works and doesn't
work
it's a great phrase from manga where he
says I study what works and doesn't work
and why and so this is the shortcut that
I'm trying to give to our listeners and
to my readers and to myself because I'm
lost half the time is to say oh that's
what works and then if you try to be
directionally correct
in all of these different ways over time
it becomes overwhelmingly powerful in
the short term you won't necessarily see
the difference but but you stick at it
from your twenties until your 50s your
60s your 70s it's overwhelming and and
it's it's very much the same path with
investing if you if you live within your
means
and you keep tucking away money in tax
deferred Vehicles like IRAs 529 plants
401K plans it seems so banal and
meaningless in the short term because
you're looking like oh wow I just put
away five thousand dollars that's gonna
help me retire and then you look back 10
20 30 years later and you're like
oh yeah that's a few hundred thousand
dollars now
and another double which is like 10
Returns a year for seven years and it's
over a million and then another seven
years and it's a couple of million three
million and then it's 10 million and and
so that that idea of
dogged incremental progress over time
that's profoundly important and the
great advantage that your listeners have
is that they're starting early and so if
you start with good habits early on in
all of these areas exercise Health
relationships getting control over your
inner landscape over your mind your your
your ability to handle stress and
uncertainty knowing how to distinguish
between what you can control and what
you can't control
living within your means saving
um exercise meditation all of these good
habits you don't have to do everything
you don't have to be optimal you want to
be directionally correct pick a few and
and so there's a there's a beautiful
line that I quote from manga where he
says take a simple idea and take it
seriously and so when you come across
one of these ideas like deferring
gratification cloning what people are
smaller than you know and figured out
already being directionally correct
adopting habits that are going to
compound over time like compounding
Goodwill
you don't have to pick all of them but
find a few things that resonate deeply
for your personality where you're just
like hey
you know with a lot of truths in life
you knew it already and somebody said
something you're like uh okay
and so in a way it's the stuff that you
know already in your own mind and it
gets activated by someone saying it and
then you're like okay I'm gonna be less
of a prayer for the next 50 years I'm
gonna try to be kinda and to God what I
say because because I know
the being kind
is an overwhelming priority if the goal
in life is to have great relationships
that are really rich and fulfilling and
have great experiences with people and
have great partners and and so there's a
there's a beautiful line from
um
manga where he says um
if you want to have a good partner be a
good partner
and so if you apply that to every area
if you apply that to Friendship you want
to have good friends be a good friend
and so these truths are not super
complicated
but as but as manga says about investing
it's simple not easy and all of these
things are simple not easy it's it's I
can't tell you how hard it is for me to
control my eating
um you know it's like I stress it and I
get bored and I you know and I like
bread and stuff you know it's not easy
for me to keep my health in gear it's
not easy for me to keep getting on the
Peloton well and a lot of this may seem
trite but it's only because you see
these these quick Instagram quotes where
you don't internalize anything yeah and
so although it is it may seem common to
some very very few people actually
internalize it set it as a habit yeah um
and start to reinforce it on a daily
basis where that becomes them
um yeah and I think that's why I've read
your book three times at this point
because I'm trying to internalize this
cheat code and ingrain it in into my
soul and uh that's that's a that's
that's wonderful and that's exactly what
I'm after it's
it's not it's not something that you
want to look at and say yeah here's a
good idea and then your eyes glaze over
and you move on to the next thing you
you want to take a few simple but
powerful ideas and make them a part of
your soul something like cloning even on
a very simple level like like years ago
when I was coming out when I was
deciding to set up my website
um williamgreen.com was gone so I'm like
what does Michael Lewis do Mike Lewis a
great writer and I look at Mike Lewis's
website and it's uh Michael Lewis
writes.com okay williamgreen writes.com
and then I look at my friend Malia and
she's got Malia Boyd writes.com and I
can see she's just cloned what I did and
I remember at one point
I did a I did a an event with Harvard
um I guess it was uh
the Harvard Club in New York and there's
brilliant woman interviews me on
there and it was a you know it was a
virtual event it was a whatever like 6
30 in the evening or 5 45 or something
and then I was going to do an event with
guy Spear and I just said to him well
the Harvard Club their virtual events or
at this time and he's like okay we'll do
it now and and it wasn't even we didn't
even discuss this for three seconds we
just cloned what these people who were
really smart had figured out already and
so you can do it in really small ways
but then you can also say okay I can
clone manga saying if you want to have a
good partner be a good partner and then
if you really take that seriously then
you say well what is a good partner
and then you start thinking well
said someone who's not just out for
themselves that someone so there's a
there's a wonderful thing in in this
book by Janet Lowe that's a biography of
of manga
where there's a forward from Buffett and
Buffett says something like in in 41
years I've never seen Charlie try to
take advantage of anyone and he says I
I've seen him knowingly take the worst
end of the deal on multiple occasions
and when there's blame
uh he takes more more of the blame than
he's due and less of the credit than
he's due and so you think about that you
think about this as one it's basically
the most successful Financial
partnership in history between Buffett
and manga and it's built on that on on
that kind of honesty and decency and
then you look at Nick sleep's
partnership with Kate Zakaria and and
Nick said it's a relationship built on
kindness and so years after they closed
down the Nomad fund this hedge fund that
had made astronomical returns they still
share an office
on the Kings Road in London and they
don't go there very often like but when
I went there years ago to interview them
it's still got you know Nick you know
Zach doesn't even have a have a desk he
has like this this big leather comfy
chair the sort of easy chair that he can
lean back on I mean that was super
informal but the fact that years after
they closed down their business they
still want to share an office
that's that's a successful relationship
and so just knowing
take taking a simple idea like cloning
and understanding it's ramifications in
every area of your life that is small
and big that that's hugely powerful so
so the fact Journey that you're picking
a few things and you're pounding it into
your brain over and over again that's I
think that's the secret I think it's
it's again it's it's removing a lot of
complexity can go and narrow and deep
well and uh you know coming to the
realization where we set up all these
novelty ideas in our head where if I
make a million dollars then I'll be
happy yeah and stress is just part of
the human condition and once you make a
million dollars then you're just
thinking about okay well how do I not
lose this a million dollars and the
stress just switches so yeah
um it then just becomes a matter of well
what what would I be really happy to do
and specialize on and and even if I'm
stressed I love what I do and instead of
thinking about all these quick gimmicky
ways or being Bobby Axelrod from
billions yeah
um and so yeah uh it is really the path
of being richer wiser happier which
opens yeah personally the possibility to
greater wealth versus hey let me try and
get rich quick and
uh be miserable in the process what
you're looking for is a kind of true
abundance and so to understand what
constitutes true abundance is it really
is a really valuable thing and so
so there's no question at all that what
the money gives you is Independence the
the for me I'm not super rich or
anything but but I've done well enough
that I don't have to do
projects that I don't want to do I can't
tell you what a gift that is not to have
to work for people who are [ __ ] or
who are bullies or that like there is
such for my particular personality which
is kind of profoundly independent
um
and profoundly
uh intolerant of bullies and Thugs and
the like and untalented people who think
they're really talented and you know
like like and impose their view on you I
mean yeah you know which I'm sure
applies to me as well
um
that's really important to me and so
so to know
that I'm prepared to sacrifice a lot of
money
to to do the work that's true to who I
am that I value and that where I can add
value in the world that's a really
valuable lesson that I've learned from
the greater investors
so you're you're trying constantly to
figure out
what real wealth actually is and it's
not it's not the flashy car I mean maybe
you're someone who really just
absolutely adores the design of a
Ferrari or a Maserati or something I I
think I think they're great I just don't
give a damn I I literally I somehow have
managed in
more than seven years not to get my car
washed once uh and it's uh I think there
are a few times where my wife is kind of
capitulated you know I just don't care
that's just not that's not what I care
about but that I really value and it's
really interesting and having the time
to have a conversation like this or to
to read and to think and to meditate and
to write and to
um to study that that is so valuable to
me I can't even tell you and so so to
know that for me that's what constitutes
an abundant life is really really
important so when I was just thinking
if I make x amount it's going to fill
this hole this big psychic Hole uh and
it's going to make me feel full and it's
like no pretty I'm not saying this in
any way to be self-congratulatory pretty
much the first thing I did this morning
pretty much the only thing I did this
morning is I gave away some money to a
cause that is deeply idiosyncratic I
mean it's it's it's a uh I didn't tell
my wife that I said luckily she won't
listen to this either but it's a it's a
translation of an ancient text
um so it's a really beautiful and really
important tax that's written in Hebrew
as I'm contributing to to that
um
that I mean that's valuable to me yeah
it's a very profound spiritual text that
is probably 500 years old and that
hasn't been translated into English and
so just to know that part of an abundant
life for me is actually not to be
controlled by money not to feel like
um I've got to make more I've got a
horde I've got you know I've had so much
fear about money over the years and so
part of part of what giving money away
does for you is it releases that sense
of
um fear and that sense of hoarding that
sense of I I'm not going to have enough
and what if I don't have enough and I'm
not
suggesting that people should be
Reckless about giving money away
um
but understanding
that you have these things to give
whether it's your money your time your
love your insights your wisdom
um your physical strength whatever it is
and and if they're just for you
you're going to have a stunted life
whereas if you've share them you're
going to have a happier life and so just
understanding the principles of the the
universal principles of life then you're
like oh yeah so I should give money away
I should make that actually a consistent
part of what I should do because
I mean I just felt happier after doing
it and
so so so it's about it's about learning
these universal laws of Life what works
and what doesn't work and why and then
and then just plugging away in a
directionally correct place so so yeah
we can't control what's going to happen
with
um
the geopolitical situation with with the
epidemiological situation which is the
word I don't get to use very often
um uh and I'm probably misusing with
climate I mean we can have a little
impact on these things
um and we should try I mean and I mean
we should think carefully about who we
vote for and who we give money to and
stuff like that but we can control our
own behavior
and and that radiates out in ways that
are really powerful and so this is an
ancient stoic truth right that you the
stoic philosophers in Rome and Greece
really really concentrated on
distinguishing between what they could
control and what they couldn't control
right and likewise I interviewed Ray
dalio recently his most successful hedge
fund manager of all time
um financially I mean make tens of
billions of dollars to the shareholders
and he had lost his son
um he died in a car accident and I I was
talking to him about how he'd dealt with
it and one of the things he said is
found really helpful is the Serenity
Prayer which is
you know again it's about distinguishing
between what you what you can and can't
control being at peace with what you
can't control so again it gets to that
idea we were talking about before of
surrender of of letting go of what you
can't control
um
and really focusing
focusing on there's so much that you can
control in terms of your own mindset
your own behavior and so so far from
feeling disempowered
or worried about the future
I think you're you're a listener should
be feeling really pretty excited about
it but if they take control of their own
behavior and their own thoughts
particularly your thoughts which I mean
you you
your inner life your Consciousness the
way you speak to yourself the way you
um
the way you think has such a profound
impact
on
um
on what happens in your life
the results over decades are going to be
overwhelming and you'll look back at 30
40 50. you'll be like really that
actually worked that that experiment
um and that's a that's a magnificent
thing and so so if I if I can help to
speed things along for you so you make
fewer mistakes than I made along the way
and don't chase after the wrong thing
that's that that would be a wonderful
thing so I hope in 20 30 years you'll be
saying that word and thank you for that
and I would highly recommend the
audience go look at the book richer
wiser happier uh definitely worth your
time
um I just want to say thank you for the
amazing insights wisdom
um making all of us wiser and happier
hopefully richer
um yeah is it uh before uh we just we go
is there
um anywhere people can find you that you
prefer so they can check out your work
besides the book oh uh I I'm relatively
active on Twitter where I'm William
Green 72 I'm on LinkedIn people are
welcome to follow me connect with me
message me I like hearing from people
I'm not always on top of replying to
them but I do try and uh
um and my website as I mentioned
williamgreenrights.com and I I would I
would encourage you to listen to the new
podcast which is the ritualized happier
podcast because I've had these long
in-depth conversations with people like
Howard marks and Joe Greenblatt who I
and there's a new one with Jason's wife
who's a terrific uh columnist at the
Wall Street Journal who
um also edited and updated the
intelligent investor which is that what
Buffett describes as by far the best
book about investing ever written and so
their in-depth conversations where
you're talking about these issues of how
to invest how to think better but also
how to live more wisely and I I think
part of the secret in life is to create
a kind of intellectual environment the
intellectual spiritual philosophical
empowerment a physical environment for
yourself in which you're going to thrive
and I think you want to pick some really
good role models in life who are
honorable decent successful smart wise
people who you admire and and none of
these people are perfect all of us are
profoundly flawed and we do stupid stuff
um but but you but you want to find a
bunch of people who you admire
um and have them in your intellectual
orbit and so to spend time in the
presence of people like manga Buffet
um Ben Graham Ben Franklin they don't
have to be alive I mean
um manga talks about hanging out with
the eminent dad
um people like Darwin and Einstein and
and uh Richard Feynman and and uh Ben
Franklin he's like I have had all my
conversations with Ben Franklin I don't
need to have a dinner with Ben Franklin
you know and and so when you're
listening to these people speak
um you're creating a kind of environment
for you that's reinforcing and and I was
telling you before this conversation
Jeremy you should go to Omaha for the
for the Birch Hathaway meeting and one
of the reasons you do it is because it
reinforces good behavior it's you're
putting your your you're saying I'm part
of this team
and so you're aligning yourself
with people who think long term who are
honest about their mistakes who
um
treat their investors as partners not as
people are going to rip off but
um as people who are going to get
wealthy with them alongside them and so
choose your environment well and so so
I think for me yeah I I hope you listen
to those conversations but I hope you'll
also do things like by Joe greenblack's
books buy Howard marks books listen to
their other podcasts listen to manga
speak read manga's book poor Charles
Almanac
um
keep
being careful about
um who you have in your environment
and and and have them support good
behavior there's a there's a there's a
great I I'm pretty ignorant about
Buddhism but I'm doing a course at the
moment
um uh that I'm live streaming
um and they talk about taking refuge in
um
uh Buddha Dharma Sangha and so Buddha
you know so it's like the light God
whatever whatever you want to think um
uh Dharma the truth like Torah Old
Testament for me
um and Sangha which is like community
and so you need your Sangha you need
your community that reinforces good
behavior and so if you're hanging out
with the guy Spears and the monish pub
rights people who care about truth and
care about treating people decently and
honorably uh
they their their behavior has been
reinforced by hanging out
with Buffett a manga right and and so
create that environment for yourself and
and it's good if it's physical if you
can go if you can go be in their
physical orbit great but you can also
just read Buffett's shareholder letters
um you can listen to his his lectures
and so so yeah sorry this is a very
long-winded way of answering your
question but I think but I think it's
important choose choose your environment
carefully
um there's a there's a great Catalyst
called ravashlag who said how important
it is to choose the right environment
because you won't change your
environment your environment will change
you
and so and and this goes back to what
Buffett says where he says hang out with
people who are better than you and you
can't help but improve so you're
constantly trying to hang out
mentally physically spiritually
psychologically with people who who are
gonna who are gonna tilt the balance for
you because we all have both sides right
so so you just want to hang out with
people who can tilt the balance towards
being being a decent honorable
successful productive human being
amazing well thank you so much I'll shut
up because otherwise you'll never stop
me talking no amazing I'm looking
forward to everyone pulling insights
from this uh I definitely have myself so
definitely a lot of internal
contemplation and thinking I will be
doing in the woods afternoon about this
conversation we had so thank you so much
uh thank you it's been a real Delight
perfect and and I wish all of you listen
as much success on this journey it's uh
it's a it's a it's an unfolding
Adventure but if you if you if you
follow some of these ideas that we've
called from these people you'll you'll
you'll look back and you'll be like wow
that worked definitely thank you if you
like that video check out this video
right here with guy spear on the pursuit
of Building Wealth and wisdom I'll see
you there investing is an infinite game
Jeff Bezos he doesn't walk around saying
look how rich I am if anything he says
look at the amazing company that I've
built